[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas finalmente zarpó
desde el puerto ucraniano de Odessa el
primer barco cargado con cereales los
granos ucranianos de los que dependen
muchos países para abastecerse habían
estado bloqueados desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa un acuerdo mediado por
Turquía y Naciones Unidas genera
esperanzas de poder aliviar la crisis
alimentaria derivada del conflicto
además de acusar a Moscú desbloquear sus
puertos kiev también señala a Rusia de
destruir deliberadamente las cosechas
disparando directamente contra los
campos informe de Gulliver crack y
judovic de fuckro
Campos en llamas una imagen común en
Ucrania este verano y la causa suele ser
evidente
hace una semana o una semana y media
hubo un ataque mira todavía puedes ver
los cohetes uno por allí dos tres cuatro
hemos perdido alrededor de 500 toneladas
a los precios del año pasado eso se
supone unos 130.000 euros las armas
utilizadas presuntamente son municiones
de racimo
corresponderá a la investigación
establecer exactamente de qué tipo se
trata pero es gracias a los cohetes de
racimo que tenemos la situación que se
ve aquí están quemando nuestros Campos a
propósito los misiles iban realmente
dirigidos a los cultivos o simplemente
fallaron un objetivo militar quemar los
cultivos no tiene ningún valor táctico
en sí mismo pero los cereales son
cruciales para la economía de Ucrania
y Víctor se dan cuenta que es tiempo de
salir
el bombardeo ha comenzado de nuevo Así
que vamos a salir de aquí creo que
apuntan a los cables eléctricos aéreos
Así que nos alejamos de ellos a toda
velocidad
disminuimos la velocidad al aproximarnos
a un pueblo cercano que ha sido
bombardeado pero que se considera
relativamente seguro aquí olex y entrega
Víctor un cargamento de ayuda
humanitaria la distribuirá entre los
agricultores y otros ser residentes más
cercanos a la línea del frente de
combate
hay bombardeos todos los días pero
hacemos lo que podemos seguimos saliendo
a trabajar tenemos que hacerlo
cosechar a pesar de los peligros en las
últimas semanas las cifras oficiales
muestran un claro aumento del número de
misiles que golpean y dañan las tierras
de cultivo
Perú tiene la gasolina más cara de
latinoamérica según un reporte de
bloomberg la agencia financiera señala
que el precio del galón de gasolina es
de 6.3 dólares en promedio la razón los
impuestos elevados la onerosa cadena de
comercialización y los altos costos de
producción de las refinerías entre tanto
los peruanos buscan otras alternativas
para poder abastecer sus autos con
combustible nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías nos amplía la
información en este reporte
Luis Alcántara fabrica muebles de acero
y en sus ratos libres es taxista sin
embargo debido al elevado precio de la
gasolina ha decidido modificar su carro
a Gas Natural vehicular para poder
Seguir generando ingresos como conductor
para todos desde la situación tan
crítica por eso ya con cambiándole ya la
mayoría se borra Pero hay algunos que
también viven del taxi normal y Peor
debe ser yo que tengo otro trabajo ahí
estoy ahí también pataleando allá Pues
poco a poco ya Ojalá que todo esto pase
así como Luis muchos peruanos están
recurriendo a la conversión de sus
vehículos de gasolina a Gas Natural
aprovechando un financiamiento Estatal
sin intereses eso permitirá a los
usuarios un ahorro mensual de cerca del
70%.
según la asociación de estaciones de
servicio en el último año los precios de
las gasolinas de 90 y 95 octanos han
subido 35 y 47% respectivamente las
causas del sobreprecio impuestos
elevados una onerosa cadena de
comercialización y los altos costos de
producción de las refinerías El
combustible sube todo porque todo se
transporta
con algo que gaste combustible y acá
pagamos Los sueldos millonarios de los
funcionarios de Petro Perú y sus coimas
en todo lo que compran eso es lo que
estamos pagando Por eso pagamos El
combustible más caro de Sudamérica según
los analistas el elevado precio de la
gasolina repercutirá negativamente a
largo plazo en la economía peruana ese
aumento muy fuerte del precio de los
combustibles
obviamente está haciendo que la
inflación suba fuertemente y golpee más
a los que menos tienen por qué Porque
los sectores de bajos ingresos más del
50% de su gasto diario lo destinan
alimentos y combustibles
el estado ha destinado a más de 630
millones de dólares en exoneraciones
tributarias y subsidios es un intento de
combatir el alza de los combustibles no
obstante diversos agentes económicos
prevén que durante Julio los precios
seguirán altos y que la inflación
alcanzará el 9%.
la iglesia mexicana alza la voz ante la
creciente inseguridad en México tras el
asesinato de dos sacerdotes Jesuitas en
el estado de Chihuahua las autoridades
eclesiásticas han salido de su histórico
silencio y sean pronunciado en contra de
la política de seguridad del gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador la
institución suele ser la única que
realiza trabajo de campo en los
territorios más hostiles los
viajaron al terreno
sí quiero activar monitoreo este botón
de pánico lo necesito porque me muevo en
zonas de riesgo
estas medidas preventivas no evitaron
que el padre Filiberto Velázquez se
enfrentará a los grupos armados a partir
de ahora una patrulla de la guardia
nacional lo escoltará cuando viaje por
la Sierra de Guerrero he sido retenido
por ellos En una ocasión por eso fue que
que no puedo estar ahí arriba así sin la
seguridad en esta zona remotas los
narcotraficantes han tomado el control
total hoy el sacerdote se dirige a San
Jerónimo una comunidad indígena donde
cinco personas fueron asesinadas por
hombres armados en un pueblo cercano en
2015 la guerra del narcotráfico con
Felipe Calderón inició Pues todo un
rompimiento de las estructuras
delictivas y empezaron a utilizar
diferentes estrategias para mantener el
control de las zonas y una de eso fue a
armar a los Indígenas los habitantes de
San Jerónimo viven ahora con miedo a los
secuestros y los constantes ataques a
través de grupos de discusión todos
comparten sus experiencias sobre estos
problemas actuales
mataron a mi padre en 2015 y cuatro años
después mataron a mi madre que buscaba
justicia para él además de décadas de
impunidad la actual política de
seguridad bajo el lema abrazos no balas
también es mencionada por el sacerdote
de una escalada de violencia como la que
está en México
ese eslogan se ve rebasado con más de
120.000 homicidios el gobierno de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador es ya el más
mortífero de México la advertencia de la
iglesia sobre la gravedad de la
situación Podría tener consecuencias
políticas en Colombia está el que es
considerado como uno de los ríos más
hermosos del mundo durante una temporada
al año sus aguas toman distintos colores
destacando el rojo gracias a una planta
conocida como macarenia clavijera sin
embargo está en un Paraje único
amenazado por la deforestación lo que
podría poner en riesgo a esta belleza de
la naturaleza nuestros corresponsales
Luis Muñoz y Diana Sánchez estuvieron en
el lugar
está en Colombia y dicen que es el río
más hermoso del mundo
Disney lo escogió en su película Encanto
como lugar en el que surge la magia las
leyendas cuentan que un arcoiris se
derritió y le dio cinco colores pero
durante décadas fue también el balneario
de la guerrilla de las FARC
Lady Aguilar es guía en Caño cristales
cada día acompaña turistas de todo el
mundo
bueno acá como vemos vemos las macareñas
clavijeras las que le dan el colorido al
caño en este momento están rosadas
estas plantas muestran su color entre
mayo y noviembre es un fenómeno único en
el mundo este año se esperan más de
14.000 turistas en 2012 ingresaron poco
más de 3.800 bueno ha cambiado porque
para nadie era un secreto Esa era la
Zona Roja Sí donde mucha gente decía no
voy porque Zona Roja pero en este
momento como estamos viendo es
totalmente algo seguro con el acuerdo de
paz de 2016 el Estado a través del
ejército tomó control de la Macarena y
de zonas turísticas como caño cristales
pero en las zonas Rurales todavía hay
presencia de grupos armados ilegales
la deforestación desde 2015 antes de los
acuerdos de paz hasta 2018 dos años
después aumentó cerca de un 92% en el
parque nacional de la Sierra de la
Macarena
Carlos garzón Es guardia forestal de
parques nacionales de Colombia
para llegar al de la Macarena debe
cruzar el río guayabero un peligro para
cualquier Guardia colectivo bajo amenaza
aquí es bastante digamos
[Música]
peligroso entre comillas porque digamos
que una entidad ambiental en un lugar
donde han vivido el conflicto armado de
manera directa pues es bastante complejo
en mi mano izquierda pueden observar un
poco de la deforestación Perdón que
tenemos dentro de la Macarena Este es un
ejemplo de un incendio que acabó con más
de 3.800 hectáreas de bosque la pérdida
de fauna y flora acelera los efectos de
la crisis climática en nosotros
realmente somos Afortunados hasta el
momento Pero si seguimos de pronto
dejando avanzar el tema de la
deforestación y pues vamos a terminar de
pronto con tierras áridas crisis
climática que amenaza a los ríos de
colores de la Macarena la subida de las
temperaturas puede provocar más sequías
que ponen en peligro a una planta que ha
maravillado a generaciones
queremos agradecer a garabato libros por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
grabación de este programa y a ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en francés 24 y 24.com